سبتم وطابتها اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى اخبار
الساعه نبداها بابرز العناوين
في الشوط الاول للمنتخب الفرنسي يسجل هدفا
في مرمى المغرب في المباراه المؤهله
لنهائي كاس العالم وتفاؤل العربيه بفوز
اسود الاطلس
على وقع مباراه المغرب وفرنسا استنفار
امنيه في باريس وبروكسيل تحسبا لاي انفلات
خارجي اطار الاحتفالات
تركيا تصفي حسابات مع معارضيها قبل
الانتخابات رئيس بلديه اسطنبول يتحدث
قرارا قضائيا بحبسه
روسيا تحضر واشنطن تجر العالم لحرب
العالميه الثالثه والاخيره تكشف عن خليه
تهريب لتقنيات العسكريه لموسكو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم نبدا اخبار اليوم اخبار الساعه
باكثر الاحداث التي تخطف انذار العالم
الان هي مباراه حاسمه بين منتخبي المغرب
وفرنسا للتاهل لنهائي كاس العالم الذي
سبقه اليهما المنتخب الارجنتيني النتيجه
حتى الان هدفنا المنتخب الفرنسي مقابل لا
شيء للمنتخب المغربي امل كبيره يعلقها
العرب على فوز تاريخي لمنتخب المغرب ومن
ساحات المشجعين متابع هذه الصور
المباشره هنا من الدوحه متابع من ساحه
المشجعين بانتظار ان يفعل هالمنتخب
المغربي ليسجل هدف في التعادل ومن ثم
تتغير مجريات هذه المباراه
وهذه الصور الاخرى ايضا ما يبدو انها من
المغرب من ساحه التشجيع للمنتخب المغربي
كما نعلم هناك الكثير من الدول العربيه
اليوم وحتى غير الدول العربيه هناك تجمعات
همم الجاليات العربيه لمتابعه هذه
المباراه هذا اول تاهل لمنتخب عربي
وافريقيا يصل الى هذه المرحله من من بطوله
كاس العالم من الرباط مراسل العربيه عدل
الزبير عادل ما هي الاوضاع اكيد المغاربه
تتعلق عيونهم وقلوبهم
بشاشات التلفاز لمتابعه اي متغيرات في
احداث هذه المباراه
نعم عادل 45 دقيقه من الوقت القانوني
الشوط الثاني من هذه المباراه ستتركز
انظار المغاربه على اسود الاطلس من اجل
العوده في المباراه وقد كانوا قريبين ان
يفعلوها بضربه مقصيه كادت ان تكون هدفه
التعادل في شباك المنتخب الفرنسي المغاربه
الان يرفعون اكفهم الى السماء تضرعا ودعوه
لان هذا المنتخب ذهب بعيدا ابعد مما توقعه
المغاربه والعرب والافارقه هذا منتخب
الاحلام يعول عليه المغاربه ان يسمح لهم
باستمرار في حلقات مسلسل الافراح لان اسود
الاطلس ونحن هنا في هذه المقعه في هذه
المقهى في قلب شارع محمد الخامس في قلب
العاصمه المغربيه الرباط الناس لن تقبل في
هذه الليله الا نسينا خلينا نتلمساءهم
خلينا نشوف هؤلاء الناس ماذا يقولون ما
الذي ياملون خلال الدقائق القادمه
نعم حسنا ااا ااا السلام عليكم وعليكم
السلام توقعاتك من الشوط الثاني
وانتداراتك من الركراكي وليداته والمنتخب
الان والمتاخر
الفوز في الشوط الثاني ان شاء الله وهو
يكون خير ان شاء الله وشكرا
اااه في ظل يعني الطاكسي الذي اصبح يلعبوه
في نهايه الشوط الاول نقدروا نتوقع انه
سيعود ان شاء الله لانه واصل اراء المواطن
المشاهدين المغاربه والمتابعين في هذه
المقهى
الامال الكبيره وعريضه همم شباب همم
تتوقع ان المنتخب المغربي يرجع في الشوط
الثاني
من الممكن علاش لا
جاك للمنتخب الشوط الاول
ان شاء الله
باذن الله
اضافيه
لباقه ثقه باقه ثقه ما احد باقي ثقه
45 دقيقه ستكون طويله على اعصاب الجمهوريه
التعادل توقعاتك
الكل يتحدث عن الخير وعن فعل الخير
وهذه الكتيبه التي افرحت المغاربه الان 45
دقيقه سوف تتحطم فيها اعصاب المغاربه صبرا
وتضرعا ودعاء من اجل ان يعود المنتخب
المغربي على الاقل بهدف وربما تذهب
المباراه الى الاشواط الاضافيه خذها مني
احساسي راح يفعلها المنتخب المغربي انا
عادل لا تذهب بعيدا سنعود اليك خلينا نروح
الى الدوحه المغاربه اليوم في ملعب البيت
والبيت بيتك يا المنتخب المغربي سيفعلها
بالتاكيد ليثاري اترك التليفون وركز وياي
يفعلها ولا ما يفعلها شو يقول الجمهور يلا
ان شاء الله يفعلها نعم نعم عدا ان شاء
الله يفعلها وانا احاول ان ارصد ما يحدث
على ارض هذا الملعب البيت بيت الشعر
الاكبر في قطر مستدي البيت الذي نشاهد
خلفي وكما تشاهد يعني هنا في الصوره يوجد
فقط قوات ام قبل قليل حاول بعد الشباب
الموجودون في هذه الساحه الاقتراب من
البوابه الرئيسيه للملعب لمحاوله الحصول
على تذاكر للدخول او للدخول
لمشاهده المباراه عن كتب وعن قرب وان
يكونوا من بين الذين يشاهدون ويشجعون
باصواته تافات كما نسمع لا ادري اذا مسموع
في هذا المايك ولكن الاصوات اا يعني قويه
داخل الاستاد وقامت القوات الامن طبعا
بادعها هؤلاء الشباب وجعلها على ان يكون
يعني معناته
خلاص على امل
كم كم عدد الحضور في في اي معلومات قبل
المباشر
نعم 68 1422
68000 1422 مشجع داخل الملعب منهم الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون الذي جاء لتشجيع
المنتخب الفرنسي طبعا والكثير من الشباب
الذين يعني قبل المباشر بدقائق شاهدنا
شابان يحميلان تذاكر لمشاهده المباراه حتى
ولو بالشوط الثاني حتى ولو في الدقائق
الاخيره شاهدت شباب ياتون فقط ليكون داخل
الملعب ويعيشون هذه اللحظات التاريخيه
التي لا تحصل كثيرا همم خصوصا ان
المونديال يقام كل اربع سنوات ولكن يعني
نشاهد هنا في الصوره همم
القوات الامن التي تحاول ان همم ترصد من
يحمل تذكره لاتاحه المجال له بان يدخل
ويحضر المباراه
تقريبا 43 دقيقه ولكن سوف نرى ما سيحدث لا
ننسى ما حدث بين فرنسا وسويسرا يعادل تمام
اذا بدا الشوط الثاني ولا لم يبدا
زين يعني الحين بدانا بال 45 دقيقه
انت تقدر تشوف انا ما اقدر اشوف شيء والله
طيب خليني اسالك عن قبل قبل بدايه هذا
المباراه نروح المعنويه شلون الخوف كان
موجود لدى الجماهير المغربيه وحتى
الجماهير العربيه التي اتت لي مسانده
المنتخب المغربي
المنتخب
المباراه وحتى هذه اللحظه لم تنتهي هذه
المباراه هذا الانتباه يعني
يعادل اولا المنتخب المغربي فرنسا وبعد
ذلك يفوز ولو بنقطه هي النقطه المهمه
النقطه الاصعب التي ستنقل المنتخب المغربي
الى الدوري النهائي الذي سيواجه الارجنتين
في نهائي كاس العالم هنا في قطر
عندي احساس انه يقول المنتخب
يعني
ما ادري لكن خليني اروح الى الرباط مره
اخرى همم
اليوم همم على الورق المنتخب
فرنسي منتخب ليس بالسهل ولكن ما الذي كان
يدعو الى التفاؤل بالنسبه للمغارب على
ماذا كانوا يراهنون هل الروح فقط تكفي
لانه المنتخب المغربي مرهق مباريات قويه
عادل نحن الان نلعب بمنتخب مغربي هو
الافضل افريقيا وعربيا والافضل في تاريخ
كره القدم المغربيه الان الشوط الثاني
وانا اتابع معك المباشر واسرق النظارات من
الشاشه المنتخب المغربي يسترجع المبادره
المنتخب الفرنسي هذا بالكامل منتخب فرنسا
في الدفاع المنتخب المغربي الان يهاجم
المنتخب المغربي قريب من التسجيل الهدف
التعادل اذا تيسرت الامور والمنتخب
الفرنسي الان يلعب فقط على راس حربه ما
يعني ان تكتيكيا وفنيا ورياضيا المنتخب
المغربي بدا يسترجع زمام المضادره يقول
المغاربه ان الهدف الفرنسي الهدف التقدم
كان سيف غدر يعني جاء بطريقه سريعه همم
اختل توازن المنتخب المغربي قبل ان تعود
كتيبه الى الاستقرار والتوازنها وفرض
اسلوبي لاعبها سنرى شوطا ثانيا جميلا
لفنيات كرويه مغربيه تليق بالكره
الافريقيه والمغربيه والع وتليق بان تتابع
لاننا الان بدانا نرى قدره مغربيه على
استرجاع المبادره الكرات القصيره
والانسلال من الاجنحه معذره اتحولت الى
محل رياضي طيب عادل الزبيري شكرا لك حتى
الان سنكون معك في هذه النشره همم يعني
سنعود اليك كذلك الشكر موصول الى ليث
بزاري من الدوحه وسنعود اليكم الان نذهب
الى اجواء بعض العواصم العربيه
للمشجعين همم اعتقد مراسله العربيه من
عمان سوها جميل ومن القاهره مراسل العربيه
احمد عثمان ايضا سيكونوا جاهز جاهزين معنا
طيب هم الان معنا على الهواء ليبدا مع سهى
سهى الوضع في عمان كيف هو وشوط الثاني بدا
مره اخرى على الدفاع
منذ بدايه الشوط الاول كما تسمع الان يعني
الحماس على اشده الجميع يترقب ان يسدد
المنتخب المغربي في هذا الشوط الثاني هدف
التعادل خاصه وان المنتخب الفرنسي سجل
هدفا في بدايه الشوط الاول ولكن على ما
يبدو ان المنتخب الفرنسي يتوجه بقوه ولكن
يعني الحظ لا يحالف له يعني لغايه اللحظه
بان يوصل الى التعادل وبذلك يعني كما ترى
الجمهور الاردني يعني سقف التوقعات
والامال والطموحات ما زالت عاليه خاصه
وانه يواجه فريق قويا والمنتخب الفرنسي
طبعا والمنتخب المغربي
فرق قويه ايضا واستطاع الوصول هذه الدقائق
في هذه المباراه قد تكون الاصعب عربيه
والاصعب اردنيا يعني نحن الان اتوقع
اقتربنا على العد التنازلي النهائي لنهايه
المباراه احنا ننتظر بهدف التعادل اردنيا
الجميع يتمنى ان يكون فعلا عن المغرب قد
يستطيع الوصول الى نهائيات كاس العالم في
هذا المونديال وان يكون الفائز بهذا اللقب
عربيا الدقائق ستحسم هذا الموضوع ولكن
الامنيات تذهب الى ان يكون المغرب هو
الفريق الفائز الاداء لغايه اللحظه الجميع
راضي على هذا الاداء ولكن يعني ربما
الهدف الذي سدده المنتخب الفرنسي ب- همم
الهدف
بالمنتخب بالمغرب
بعض بعض الاحباط ولكن لغايه اللحظه هنروح
المعنويه عاليه والامنيات عاليه ونحن
ننتظر لحظه بلحظه على هذه الشاشه الانظار
تتجه الى هذه الشاشه دون ان يقطعها شيء هو
حدث عربي بامتياز ربما جمع العرب وجمع
الاردنيين على اختيار فريق واحد ومنتخب
واحد وهو المغرب لغايه اللحظه طيب خليني
اسال سؤال هل هناك مناطق ايضا مشجعين ولا
الناس يتعلقون بالمقاهي همم لمتابعه هذه
المباراه من خلف الشاشات
بالتاكيد
في حجوزات مسبقه لان يحضر المواطن الاردني
على المباريات هناك ايضا بعض الخيام التي
يعني كانت بشكل مميز وبشكل واسع وشاشات
كبيره لان يحضر برده المشاهدين والمتابعين
والمشجعين همم المباريات في مونديال قطر
يعني يتوزع الراغبين في حضور هذه المباراه
ما بين القيام الكبيره ما بين المقاهي ما
بين الاماكن المفتوحه لحضور هذه المباريات
باجواء يعني حماسيه يعني في اي مكان سواء
مقهى او خيار تكون دائما الاجواء هكذا
اجواء حماسيه ان تتعلم ان يكون هناك فريق
عربي لاول مره يصل الى منتصف في النهائيات
يعني يكون غدا سيتاهل او لا يتاهل ان شاء
الله ههه
جميله لسه حاطين المباراه في في النشره
على شاشتنا الداخليه لكن يعني خليني اقول
ان شاء الله الامل ما زال موجود باقي هذه
هجمه يلا طيب شكرا سؤال جميل ساذهب الى
الى باريس معنا من هناك فادي الداهوكم
راسلنا همم فادي
شكرا لك يسوها من عمان طيب فادي جاهز
فادي
الاوضاع عندك الاجواء البارده سخونتها
اليوم في متابعه هذه المباراه
مساء الخير عادل الاجواء حتى الان هنا في
جده الشانزليزيه هادئه حيث سوف يتجمع
المشجعون مهما كانت النتيجه هناك سوف يكون
محتفل في جده لاحقا حتى الان اتواجد لا
يوجد في هذا الشارع وانا والشرطه ان كنتم
ترونهم خلفي هناك انتشار امني كثيف جدا
الشرطه انتشرت في جده
الاحتلال التي سوف تعقب بهذا اللقاء اليوم
وهذه المباراه
اليوم
خارج اطار الاحتفالات
نعم عادل هناك مذكره امنيه للاستخبارات
الفرنسيه توقعت حدوث بعض اعمال الشغب التي
سوف تعقب الاحتفالات لكن حتى الان الامور
هادئه جدا ولهذا السبب وهناك انتشار امني
كثيف يعني هناك 10 الاف شرطي سوف ينتشرون
اليوم في كل المناطق الفرنسيه 5.000 منهم
في العاصمه باريس وضواحيها اما هنا حيث
نقص نحن الان وتشاهدون هذه الصور مباشره
يوجد 2000 نحو 22 شرطي لتامين الاحتفالات
ولكي تسير هذه الاحتفالات على ما يرام
طيره الفتره السابقه المباريات السابقه لم
تحدث هناك اي حوادث تذكر كان هناك فقط
مناوشات بسيطه حدثت همم او اعقبت مبارتي
الفريقين فرنسا مع انجلترا والمغرب مع
البرتغال همم حدثت بعض اعمال الشغب لكنها
لم تاتي من طرف المشجعين الذين كانوا
يحتفلون بكل فرح وبكل سلميه في جده هذه
الحوادث كانت في شوارع فرعيه على اطراف
هذه المنطقه لكن لان اللقاء اليوم مهم جدا
وهو يجمع فريقين لكل منهما جمهور كبير
وضخم جدا هنا في فرنسا همم هذه همم الحشود
الامنيه هي فقط حتى الان لتامين همم
الاحتفالات لكي تسير الامور على ما يرام
من دون مشاكل ايضا سوف يتم قطع او سوف يتم
اغلاق خمس بوابات تصل الى العاصمه همم الى
خصوصا الى جده سوف يتم قطعها واغلاقها
امام حركه المرور لكي يتم تجنب اي حاجه
حوادث ممكن ان تذكر خصوصا وان هؤلاء
الاشخاص الذين تتخوف منهم الشرطه قد ياتون
من خارج هذه المنطقه ويحاولون افساد فرحه
الجماهير اليوم عادل ان شاء الله همم ان
شاء الله يحتفلوا بفوز المغرب حتى لو كانت
في فرنسا المغاربه كثار في في فرنسا
والجاليه العربيه كبيره جدا فادي وانت تحت
والله يستر علينا طيب شكرا جزيلا في هذه
الداهوكم مراسل العربيه من باريس شكرا
جزيلا سنعود اليك
[موسيقى]
الى القاهره سريعا ومعنا من هناك احمد
عثمان الاجواء اجواء متابعه هذه المباراه
في البلدان العربيه المصريين ما لهمش حل
وما حدش يناقشهم في الكوره الى الاجواء
عندك
لعبه ههه
بالفعل كما قلت المصريين ما لهمش حل هناك
تفاعل كبير جدا المقاهي المصريه تبدو
وكانها تتابع مباراه للمنتخب المصري يعني
تعاطف كبير وحماسه كبيره جدا لتشييع
المنتخب المغربي هذه المباراه كانت حديث
الشارع المصري ليس فقط على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ولكن على مستوى الشارع المصري
هناك نوع من التمني الكبير في ان ينجح
المنتخب المغربي في تخطي العقبه الفرنسيه
والوصول للنهائي يعني حتى الان المباراه
من الخلفي اسمع اهات الجماهير التي تتابع
الهجمات المغربيه هناك امل كبير بانه
سيستطيع كما ذكرت انت مع الزملاء بانه
سيستطيع المنتخب المغربي احراز ال- ال-
التعادل والوصول الى المباراه النهائيه
ولكن كما ذكرته لك هناك يعني تفاعل كبير
جدا مع هذا الاداء هذا الاداء المغربي
الذي جاء مبهرا للمنتخب المصري وتجاوزه كل
الاستخبارات من مباريات عربيه عربيه او
مباريات افريقيه افريقيه جمعت ما بين
الفريقين تكاتف كبير جدا مع الجمهور
المغربي المقهى الذي اجلس فيه الان يضم
مجموعه من الجاليه المغربيه التي اتت لهذا
المقهى واشتهر هذا المقهى بسبب انتشار
الفيديوهات لتواجد الجمهور المغربي وفي
المباريات الاخيره في هذه المباراه تحديدا
عادل هناك تدفق من قبل جماهير مغربيه على
الرغم من ان الجاليه ليست كبيره مع الكثير
من الجماهير المصريه ربما عارفين مقاهي
الاخرى المنتشره سواء في القاهره وغيرها
المحافظات ستجد الزحام وتدفق الجماهير كما
ذكرت لك في بدايه هذه المداخله وكانها
مباراه للمنتخب المصري همم طيب دائما ما
يقولون بان همم القراءه للجمهور تختلف من
خلال
المتابعه التفاعل قبل هذه المباراه هل كان
الامل العالي لانه على الورق الكل يتحدث
انه المنتخب الفرنسي قد يحسم هذه المباراه
ولكن ماذا عن الشعور
نعم يعني كما ذكرت عادل يعني هناك كان
هناك ربما انقسام ما بين التمني وما بين
التوقع فيما يتعلق بالتمني فيعني كان هناك
ربما حاله كبيره جدا من الحماسه بان
المنتخب المغربي سيستطيع بادائه لراقي
خلال المباراه الماضيه والنجاح في تجاوز
فرق مثل بلجيكا وفرق مثل اسبانيا وفرق مثل
البرتغالي هذا المشهد المشرف الذي ظهر
يعني اداء سيكون هناك ربما استمرار لهذه
النجاحات وهذا التفوق والعبور الى المربع
الاخر والوصول الى المباراه النهائيه ولكن
هناك ايضا من تحدث بواقعيه كما ذكرت من
تحدث بنها من انه يعني ربما الفريق
الفرنسي وقياسا لاداء الفريق الفرنسي انه
بطل كاس العالم النسخه الماضيه وخلال
المباريات الماضيه كيف يبدا ربما سيكون
هناك ربما الان الفجر وما بين التمني
والتوقع ان هناك من ينظر الى الواقعيه
ولكن حتى من خلال ما اسمع من اهات جماهير
خلال
الدقائق الماضيه ونجاح المنتخب المغربي
نعم نجاح المنتخب المغربي للوصول الى
التهديد المرمى الفرنسي اكثر بالمرمى هذا
ما يؤكد بان ربما ليست مجرد واقعيه فقط
اذا كانت واقعيه ربما كانت النتيجه هناك
الان كبيره للمنتخب الفرنسي ولكن هو هدف
في الدقائق الاولى بشكل مبادئ وما نراه
الان من خلال الشوط الثاني هو نجاح للفريق
المغربي في الوصول وتهديد المرمى الفرنسي
على امل النجاح في احراز التعادل والوصول
الى ربما هدف اخر او وقت اضافي او نجاح
المنتخب المغربي في الوصول من خلال ضربات
الجزاء كان راينا في مباراه اسبانيا
والاداء المذهل حارس المرمى المغربي في
هذه المباراه وفي غيرها من المباريات
بالفعل يعني هناك من يرى المنتخب المغربي
ليس يعني رافعه همم فخر ليس للعرب فقط
ولكن ايضا للمنتخبات الافريقيه هذا الاداء
ربما هو ما نجح الى حد كبير في تهدئه غضب
الشارع المصري الذي غاب من هذه النسخه من
كاس العالم كانت هناك النسخه الاخيره في
2018 قبل المباراه يعني المشاركه التي قبل
كانت عامه 90 في ايطاليا وبالتالي هناك من
يتابعون المنتخب المغربي ويشجعونه
باعتباره ممثلا للعرب ولي افريقيا يعني
باجي 25 دقيقه قد تقلب فيها الموازين يعني
احساسي قلت لك انه راح يكون هدف التعادل
للمغرب عادل البقيه ان شاء الله خير عموما
احمد عثمان شكرا جزيلا لك وسنعود قد نعود
اليك في هذه النشره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طيب نتابع بعض هذه الصور المباشره
للمشجعين لمتابعه المباراه بين المنتخب
المغربي والمنتخب الفرنسي باقي اقل من 25
دقيقه 24 دقيقه على هذه المباراه
امامهم في الملعب ايضا هناك احاسيس مختلفه
على الورق كما نقول بعض المحللين كانوا
يقولون بان المنتخب الفرنسي بالتاكيد لديه
نجوم هو الاقوى هو الحاضر اكثر المنتخب
المغربي قد تكون المباريات التي اقصى فيها
همم منتخبات البرتغال بلجيكا وكذلك
اسبانيا ارهقته همم وهذا ما بدا همم في
بدايه هذه المباراه من التغيير المبكر
لاحد لاعبي المنتخب المغربي في الحقيقه ال
20 من الشوط الاول الان بوفال يخرج ايضا
لينزل همم لاعب اخر همم مكان همم بدا
الارهاق واضحا على بعض لاعبي المنتخب
المغربي ربما هي ايضا حتى الروح العاليه
همم
يبدله اللاعبون من عمليات الجري خلال
المباريات
السابقه قد تنعكس اليوم على اداء هذا
الفريق اذا ما زال ما زالنا نقول لكم هذه
الصور مباشره من ساعات همم المشجعين في
المغرب في الدوحه هذه الصور من الدوحه اذا
كمان نشاهد كثافه عدديه همم كبيره ليث
مازال قبل قليل مراسل العربيه ذكر بان همم
تذاكر لمباراه
تماما يعني اكثر من 60,000 متفرج يحضر هذه
المباراه هذه اجمل خطره الان للمنتخب
المغربي همم لكن همم ان شاء الله القادم
ظل بكثير
[موسيقى]
نتابع القليل من الاخبار في اخبار الساعه
وماذا لدينا
بعد تكبير حركه النقل عاصفه الاضرابات في
بريطانيا تنظر بتعطيل قطاع الصحه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله قضت محكمه تركيه في سجن رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول المعارضه اكرم امام اوغلو
عامين و سبعه اشهر بتهمه اهانه مسؤولين
يذكر انه خلال جلسه استماع سابقه في
نوفمبر طالب المدعي العام السجن لمده
تتراوح بين 15 شهرا الى اربع سنوات بحقي
امام اوغلو بتهمه اعضاء المجلس الاعلى
للانتخابات
من جانبه قال رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم
امام اوغلو في اول تعليق له بعد حكم سجنه
قال انه لا يمكن لاحد ان ياخذ السلطه التي
يمنحها الناخبون ووصف الحكم الصادر بحقه
بغير القانوني من جهه اكد محامي اكرم امام
اوغلو انهم سيستالفوا ضد الحكم الذي صدر
بحق رئيس بلديه اسطنبول فيما قال زعيم
المعارضه التركيه معلقا على حكم سجن رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول ان البلاد تشهد اغتيال
القانون وتعفن اداره الدوله استسلمت
لاراده شخص على حسب وصفه
[موسيقى]
قد تشهد ساحه الحرب في اوكرانيا تغيرا في
قواعد الاشتباك ربما نشهد مواجهه روسيه
امريكيه على الارض الاوكرانيه هذا ما ينذر
به التهديد الروسي بعد كشف البنتاجون
ارسال الولايات المتحده قريبا نظام
باتريوت للدفاع الجوي الى اوكرانيا
روسيا ردت فورا على القرار الامريكي حيث
قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
التي تنوي الولايات المتحده تسليمها للكيب
ستكون هدفا مشروعا للقوات الروسيه اثناء
عملياتها العسكريه في اوكرانيا وعن احتمال
توقف القتال في اوكرانيا اثناء اعياد
الميلاد ونهايه العام قالت الكلام لان
قيد البحر بهذا الشام
الدعم الغربيه العسكري وتحديدا الامريكي
الى اوكرانيا يغضب روسيا التي ترفع ورقه
التهديد في كل مره لجنه الشؤون الدوليه في
مجلس الاتحاد الروسي اعتبرت انا واشنطن
تضع العالم على شفا حرب العالميه الثالثه
عبر امداد كيف بالاسلحه وحذر من انها تسعى
ايضا لاثاره صراع مباشر بين روسيا ونيتو
وقد سبق وحضرت موسكو من ان الاسلحه التي
ترسلها الدول الغربيه الى كيد يتم بيعها
في السوق السوداء وتنتقل الى المنظمات
الارهابيه
والاجراميه ما باتى يمثل تهديدا امنيا
كبيره
[موسيقى]
خيانه وتامر من داخل الولايات المتحده ضد
اوكرانيا والي صالح روسيا قضيه نسمه فجرها
تحقيق وزاره العدل الامريكيه والذي تم
الاشياء بمسمياتها معلنا اسماء المتهمين
الامريكيين والروس في هذا الملف
وزاره العدل الامريكيه تصدير التقنيات
الامريكيه ذات طبيعه عسكريه وهذات استخدام
مزدوج لصالح قطاع الدفاع الروسي في انتهاك
للعقبات الامريكيه المفروضه على روسيا
ووجهت تهم بهذا الخصوص الى خمسه رؤوس
وامريكيين اخرين وضع الثلاثه من المجموعه
رهن الاعتقال ولا يزال اربعه من الروس
طلقاء
وذكرت لائحه الاتهام اسماء جميع المتهمين
الخمسه ومن بينهم ضباط في جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي وهو قيد الاعتقال في
استونيا وقد وقدم بشانه طلب ترحيل امريكا
ونقلا عن المدعي العام الامريكي فانا
التقنيات الامريكيه التي تم تصديرها تشمل
المكونات الالكترونيه شديده الحساسيه
ويحكم تصديرها قواعد صارمه
يمكن استخدام بعضها في تطوير اسلحه نوويه
واسلحه فوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت واجهزه
كمبيوتر فائقه السرعه وغيرها من التطبيقات
العسكريه
[موسيقى]
الجلوس على طاوله التفاوض بين كيف
ومودكولايزال حلا تطمح اليه العديد من
الاطراف لكنه لم يتحقق بعد رغم المساعي
المبذوله في هذا السياق المتحده اهم
الداعمين لاوكرانيا بحثت عده مواضيع مع
روسيا في مفاوضات سريه بين مسؤولينا من
الجانبين في اسطنبول مفاوضات كانت عمليه
لكنها لم تحرز اي تقدم من بين الجانبين
بشان الموضوعات الرئيسيه وهو ما اوضحه
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
سيرجيريا كما اكد ذات المسؤول ان
المفاوضات الاخيره ليست اشاره سياسيه
لاستئناف الحوار مع الامريكينا حول
القضايا الرئيسيه
[موسيقى]
ثيران يواجه قرابه 20 ناشطا بينهما طبيب
وفنانين ولاعب كره قدم عقوبه الاعدام التي
تستخدمها السلطات الايرانيه وسيله للترحيب
بهدف قمع الاحتجاجات وفق مجموعات حقوقيه
[موسيقى]
قدم الصحيفه كيهان المقربه من المرشد
الايراني مقترحا بغلقه مضيق هرمز الواقع
على الخليج العربي وجاء المقترح وفقر
صحيفه ردا على الدعم الاجنبيه المزعوم
للاحتجاجات الايرانيه المستمره منذ اشهر
ضد النظام في طهران وشدد رئيس تحرير صحيفه
تيهان الذي عينه المرشد علي الخامنائي على
ضروره غلق المضيق امام مناقله نفط الدول
الغربيه والسفن التجاريه ودعت الصحيفه
ايضا في مقالها الافتتاح الى حيازه
الشحنات التجاريه
كعويض عن الضرر الماليه الذي لحق بالنظام
بسبب العقوبات الغربيه
من اهم الممرات المائيه الامدادات
الطاقه العالميه
هكذا مستشار الامن القومي الامريكيه جاك
سوليفان ان الولايات المتحده تعمل مع
خلفاءها لمحاسبه ايران على انتهاكاتها بحق
شعبها تسعى لمحاسبه ايران بسبب دورها
فيزعزعه استقرار الشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]
تسليم مسعود ابو عجيله للولايات المتحده
من المتحده من اجل المحاكمه في قضيه
لوبيربي لا يزال ليشغل بال القاسي والثاني
هناك في ليبيا ويثير لغه كبيرا العديد من
الاطراف
وهو ما حدث فعله حيث اعلن النائب العام
الليبي الصديقه ااكد البدء بالتحقيق فيما
وصفه حادثه التسليم مسعود ابو عجيله الى
الولايات المتحده ايضا ان النائب العام
قال ان عمليه التسليم مجرد دون علم
السلطات القضائيه الليبيه الى ذلك ندد 44
حزبا سياسيا الليبيا بالواقعه والدعه الى
الاعتصام امام قارات الامم المتحده وسفرات
الولايات المتحده في الداخليه والخارج وفي
احد التسريبات التي تخصم ملابسات القضيه
قالت صحيفه داكار ديانا البريطانيه ان
اتفاقا جرائم قبل ثلاثه اشهر بين الاداره
الامريكيه ومسؤولين ليبينا من اجل تسليم
ابو عجيله مشيره الى ان المفاوضات بدات
منذ عهد الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب
من بنغازي مراسل العربيه محمود مسعود ينضم
الينا محمود ما هي اخر التفاصيل بخصوص ما
تحدثنا عنه
نعم يوما بعد يوم ما تتكشف المزيد او
تتكشف المزيد من التفاصيل حول هذه العمليه
سواء عمليه اختطاف سعود ابو عجيله او حتى
نتحدث عن عمليه تسليمه الى الولايات
المتحده اليوم كشف او تم الكاشف عن موقف
المجلس الرئاسي من ناحيه بعد ما كانت اغلب
المواقف التي رصدناها في الايام الماضيه
مقتصره على مجلس النواب من جهه او حتى
مجلس الامن القومي من جهه اخرى او حتى
منظمات المجتمع المدني او حتى نتحدث عن
مجلس الدوله في غربه البلاد اليوم مع
تصريحات النائب العامه وتبيان موقفه من
هذه العمليه والقول بشكل واضح بان السلطات
القضائيه في ليبيا هنا ممثله في النائب
العام لم يكن لديها علم بعمليه التسليم
حتى او حتى بالقضايا التي متهم فيها
حتى من ناحيه اخرى يعني موقف المجلس
الرئاسي الذي وضعها اليوم ببيانه
ومطالباته لحكومه الدبايبه بالضروره تبيان
حيثيات هذه العمليه ودور الحكومه الجهه
الوحيده حتى هذه اللحظه الان مع ازدياد
رقعه التمديدات اوتساع رقعه التمديدات
سواء الشعبيه او حتى على المستوى السياسي
العام في الدوله الليبيه الوحيده فقط التي
لم تبين موقفها حتى الان ويتهمها عديد او
تتهمها عديد الجهات السياسيه هي موقف
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه التي لم توضح حتى
هذه اللحظه الان موقفها بهذا الخصوص ولكن
الى غايه اللحظه الان هناك محاولات تجرى
اما على صعيد مؤسسات المجتمع مدني
والحقوقيون او حتى على المستوى الرسمي من
قبل مجلس الامن القومي وتشكيله لجنه
لتواصل مع السلطات الامريكيه بهذا الخصوص
او حتى بدا تحريك الدعوه من قبل النائب
العام المرفوعه من قبل عائله ابو عجيبه او
حتى مطالبه مجلس النواب لمكتب النائب
العام ضروره التحقيق في هذا الامر
شكرا جزيلا محمود ده مسعوده من بن غازي
مراسله العربيه
2-0 لصالح المنتخب الفرنسي ايضا لدينا في
اخبار الساعه
جديده العصفور الازرق تويتر
[موسيقى]
الى اعضاء نقابه السكك الحديديه فيما
يستعد عمال قطاع التمريض للانضمام الى
قافله المضربين وينظم عمال البريد ونقابه
عمال التوصيل اضرابا وطنيا جديده لمده 80
و40 ساعه وستدخل الممرضات في انجلترا
وويلز وايرلندا الشماليه اضرابا ل- اا
الرفع مان لي رفع الاجور بعد انهيار
المحادثات مع الحكومه
[موسيقى]
معنى من لندن مراسله العربيه على ربع عبد
الحق عروبه اهلا بك ماذا تفعل الحكومه
البريطانيه حياله هذه الاضرابات وخاصه
القادم منها
مرحبا عادل يعني يهيئ لك بان مدينه لندن
تكون مهيئه في هذا الوقت من العامل
الخدمات بشكل عام ولكن بالفعل تضرب يعني
او تشهد قطاعات مختلفه في بريطانيا هذه
الاضرابات كلها في ان واحد ابدا من
الاضطرابات التي
تطال قطاع السكك الحديديه نحن الان من
امام محطه شيرل كروس وهي في وسط لندن هذه
المحطه التي تربط مدينه لندن بالمدن خارج
هذه المدينه وهي يعني قطاع السكك الحديديه
او الريل واي وهو القطاع الذي توقف عن
العمل منذ امس واليوم ومن المتوقع ان نشد
اضرابات
لثماني مرات هذا الشهر وفي شهر يناير
لقطاع السكك الحديديه طبعا عمال او
الاعضاء النقابات نقابه السكك الحديديه
رفضت همم عرض من الحكومه بان ترفع اجورهم
بنسبه 5% في يناير واربعه بالمئه ايضا من
جديد خلال العام المقبل هم يريدون يعني ان
يكون هناك زياده في الاجور برقم اعلى من
هذا وبالتالي همم يعني بدات هذه الاضرابات
منذ امس هناك ايضا اضرابات وهي قد تكون
الاخطر همم في بريطانيا وهو ادراك قطاع
التمريض قطاع الممرضين يعني يبدا بالاضراب
غدا همم وسيكون هناك اضراب اخر في 20 من
ديسمبر وبالتالي هذا القطاع الذي يطالب
برفع الاجور بنسبه 19% اا ولكن الحكومه
رفضت هذا الرقم ايضا وكان هناك ايضا اليوم
في جلسه المساءله الحكوميه الاسبوعيه
مشاده كلاميه كالعاده بين رئيس الحكومه
وحزب العمال الذين اتهموا يعني تبادلوا
الاتهامات همم في همم نسبه الاجور هذا
واعتبر حزب العمال يعني انا تصل
الاضطرابات قطاع التمريض فهو وصفه عار على
هذه الحكومه وهناك ايضا الاضطرابات التي
تشهدها مثلا ايضا من الاضرا الخطره عمال
الاسعاف مثلا وعمال البريد عادل
عبد الحق بامكانك متابعه المباراه الان
بعد هذا المباشر شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
اوقف تويتر حسابنا استخدام بيانات رحلات
طيران متاحه على علنا لتتبع طائر الخاصه
لمالك تويتر الى مصر ياتي هذا الايقاف على
الرغم من تعهد مالك المنصه الجديد
بالالقاء عليه بسبب مبادئ حريه التعبير
ولم تعد تغريدات الحساب الذي تتبع بيانات
رحله طائره ماسك متاحه يذكر ان الحساب كان
لديه اكثر من 526,000 متابعه حتى يوم
الثلاثاء
الى العناوي
المنتخب الفرنسي يسجل الهدف الثاني في
مرمى المغرب في المباراه المؤهله لنهائي
كاس العالم
على وقع مباراه المغرب وفرنسا ستنفارون
امنيه في باريس وبروكسل تحسبا لاين فلات
خارج ايطار الاحتفالات
تركيا تصفي حسابات مع معارضيها قبل
الانتخابات رئيس بلديه اسطنبول يتحدث
قرارا قضائيا بحبسه
روسيات وحذر واشنطن تجر العالم لحرب
العالميه الثالثه والاخيره تكشف عن خليه
تهرب التقنيات العسكريه لموسكو
اترككم في رعايه الله وحفظه
[موسيقى]